Say it. I deserve it.
I deserve it.
Again.
-I deserve it.
Feels good, doesn't it?
Shrink Next Door tells the story
of a very co-dependent relationship
that spans 27 years.
Marty Markowitz and his sister Phyllis,
they've just lost their parents.
He's very vulnerable
and feels that the walls are
caving in on him.
Marty, what are you doing?
Seeing how much stress
her big brother was under,
Phyllis recommended a therapist, Ike.
At first, Dr. Ike is everything
you would hope a therapist would be,
a great listener, really helps him
solve problems.
The thing about obstacles,
they're either stumbling blocks
or stepping stones.
They're kind of having an identity crisis.
Ike is feeling a lack of fulfillment
with being a therapist.
And Marty is really ill-equipped
to deal with the obstacles
that are being thrown his way.
-You ok, buddy?
-Yeah.
Having one of my panic attacks.
It'll pass.
Ike helped him enormously
at the beginning,
then that relationship
morphed into something unhealthy.
Welcome!
Dr. Ike starts to manipulate him.
He takes over Marty's Hamptons house.
What's the big deal
if they think it's my place, huh?
-I mean, who cares whose place it is?
-I agree.
This doctor seems
a little unconventional, huh?
But the thing is, he cares so much.
It starts to get further away
from what's acceptable.
You know, sometimes I feel like
I'm working on you,
but I don't think you're working on you.
I promise. I'll work harder.
Marty doesn't realize how bad it is.
He's just thankful that
this therapist is in his corner.
-I don't trust him.
-He's trying to help me.
Phyllis was toxic.
You did the right thing
by cutting her out of your life.
By separating him from Phyllis,
Marty and Ike
really become so intertwined,
which is the heart of the story.
You are growing, Marty!
I mean, this is all because of you.
You should be proud of yourself.
I'm proud of you.
I wanted the audience to feel
sort of seduced and charmed by Ike,
just as Marty is.
Everything's gonna be all right.
I'm not gonna let anyone use you.
It's heartbreaking.
You go into it thinking,
"Well, that would never happen to me.
I'd be impervious to the journey
that this guy went on."
When you're in it,
you just think differently.
It's very easy to believe
what we wanna believe.
You know I'm doing this for you.
Anyone at any moment, feeling vulnerable,
could go down this road.
Trust is at the very core of who I am.
I do trust you.